Ca y est c'est l'été, ma saison préférée
Faux
Déjà quand c'est la première belle journée d'été,
plein soleil, chaleur caniculaire
et que pour la première fois tu sors en T-shirt dehors,
bah nous les mecs on sait plus que ça existe les mini jupes ou les décolletés et tout
c'est comme-ci on avait oublié depuis un an que ça avait existait
en !!
pppffff
Alors forcement on a tous envie de plaire quand c'est l'été, alors...
P'tit farfum, p'tite chaussure, aïe Norman
On a envie de danser le Mia
Ya un truc qui n'ait pas normal les filles pour être sexy c'est pas compliqué elle mettent un décolté ou un truc un p'tit peu légé tu vois
Et hop sa marche
Je suis parfaitement hot
Mais quand tes un mec, tu fais comment pour être sexy ?
Ya pas de frein particulière ya rien de spécial
Si ya un truc
Le short
*gros mot* mais c'est pas du tout sexy un short
Ta déjà vu une meuf qui flash sur toi parce que ta un short ?
En ! Oh my god, le beau goss !
*rire*
Sinon en ce moment on vois de plus en plus de fille qui se promène avec des pantalons tout mou, eeuuhh..
Un peu dans le venge avec des ptits motifs de fleurs de mamie dessus.
Je ne sais pas ci ca s'appelle des star welle ou peut être des pantalons de pyjamas
Attend c'est quoi ce délir ?! Bientôt sa va être swag de ce balader comme ça ?
*musique*
Bon alors oui ya du soleil et forcement t'achètes des lunettes de soleil
Alors moi j'ai eu la super idée d'acheter ces lunettes
Bon déjà
Elle sont extremement regarde
Et en plus elle donne trop l'impression d'être impressioné tout le temps
Genre
Ooohh ! Ba dis donc, whoua
Tu peux jamais t'énerver avec ces lunettes
Raaa chui en colère
Enfin bon ci vous habitait à la campagne vous avez de la chance parce que vous pouvez allait à la plage
Vous pouvez faire du rafting ou du l'escalade sauvage
Mais nous en ville si tu veux on à pas tout ça !
Et des qu'il y a un rayon de soleil ya tout tes pottes qui t'appelle pour te proposer le même truc nul
Ouais mec il fait trop beau ! Sa te dit qu'on aille se poser dans un parc ?!
*bruit*
*gros mot* posé dans un parc
nan mais sérieux ya pas plus nul quand même comme activité
s’asseoir sur l'herbe et ne rien faire !
pendant 2heures ?
3 ?
peut-être 4 !
c'est tout
Après y'en a certain, j'ai bien dit certain qui propose de faire une p'tite folie
Sa te dit qu'on aille se poser dans un parc et qu'on joue au carte ?
*bruit*
Nan mais l'été à Paris c'est nul !
Tu te prends des nuages de pollution dans la geule
Sa pu la pisse, mais bon c'est pas grave
On peut jouer au cartes dans un parc
*musique*
Si vous avait envie vous pouvez rejoindre la page Facebook NORMAN FAIT DES VIDEOS
Ou alors vous abonnez à ma chaine youtube en cliquant ici
Mais vous êtes pas obligés je veut dire voilà, chacun sa route
Chacun son chemin
Oui
Vous pouvez aussi allez sur mon site web
Normanfaitdesvidéos.com
*musique*
Traduction : SyFor Gaming